[Music]
all right hi everybody my name is Emily
Britton and I am the principal Marketing
Manager for food and natural products in
North America with Waters Corporation
and I'm really happy that I have the
opportunity to present to you all today
on this topic what does quality mean to
you analytical tools for defining a
complex
Botanical so I have a picture here
courtesy of my iPhone that I took and if
you look at it you know the picture
looks all right um it's aesthetically
pleasing um and I'm holding some sort of
Vape device in my hand looks pretty
Sleek not sure what brand it is at all
um you can see color of some sort of
product in the cartridge but despite you
know maybe a NIC looking picture or
maybe even if you extrapolate out and
you're in a store and you're looking at
products how do you really know if the
quality of the product that you're
looking at is good or bad or
sufficient I don't really
know so ultimately if we ask ourselves
if this is a quality product and that
really goes for anything in life that we
encounter we have to consider who's
asking the question and what their role
is within
the supply chain of the market because
quality means something a little bit
different to everybody so what I want to
do here is really just take a moment to
put ourselves in the shoes of others and
think about how do they Define quality
in the context of
cannabis so perhaps we can first start
with The Regulators so The Regulators
are there to ultimately keep the
consumers safe um with the products that
they are consuming right so maybe
quality means to a regulator that the
product products that are on the market
comply with regulations and that the
data that were generated um to put those
products on the market are trustworthy
Regulators may you know Define quality
as you know providers or manufacturers
having data that are trustworthy and
those validated methods are used by the
Laboratories that do the testing and
ultimately high quality to a regulator
perhaps means that the products are safe
for
consumption but if we go to the
laboratory and think about what they you
know perceive as being high quality
typically Laboratories are you know
hopefully testing the products that come
in with a fit forp purpose method using
a method that makes sense for the Matrix
that's being analyzed usually that's a
sign of quality and when they're doing
the analys of of these different
products typically they would say all
right all of the analytes all the things
that I expect that are in this product
I'm aware of what they are and I
Quantified them accurately and maybe
quality also could mean that there are
no unknowns no mystery Peaks or
contaminants that might be found within
a product that would be a way that
Laboratories May Define
quality so as we move down the supply
chain now we can think about what the
producer defines as quality the people
who manufacture these products so
perhaps to that or to them it means that
the products that they're formulating
meet Target specifications they were
aiming for a certain percentage of a
certain cannabinoid and they got it
right maybe quality can also mean that
they Source their raw materials from a
specific place whether they're growing
products and formulating them themselves
or they're you know getting biomass of
some sort or ingredients from a
manufacturer or provider that they know
and trust um Quality can also mean
perhaps different manufacturing
processes are used a lot of people you
know do some sorts of solvent extraction
some people really try to communicate
quality in their products by using you
know super critical fluid technology to
create their extracts
ultimately quality um to a producer can
ultimately mean that their products are
differentiated from the competition and
that they have some sort of edge in
their products that would make a
consumer want to pick their product over
somebody else's so I mentioned the
consumer I would say that's the end of
the supply chain at least in this aspect
and quality I think probably means
something a little bit different to
Consumers than it does maybe all the way
at the top um compared to The
Regulators so to consumers if you
imagine yourself being even in a store
and you have a selection of products
that you could pick from maybe the
things that indate or indicate quality
to you are how the packaging looks if
it's aesthetically pleasing if it's
clean refined maybe there's really
interesting marketing around it or
there's some sort of podcaster or
celebrity or an influencer that's um
endorsed these products maybe that can
mean oh well this must be good quality
because so and so really you know
Champions it another thing that
consumers think about in terms of
quality is does this product you know
elicit the biological effect that I'm
looking for um maybe maybe not um and
ultimately transparency and honesty on
labels all consumers in all areas food
Pharmaceuticals
cannabis when we shop we expect that the
labels that are on products accurately
represent what's in the bottle or in the
box so those those are the things that I
would say Define quality from all of
these different points in the supply
chain so what does poor quality cost the
industry what are the risks of not
having sufficient quality controls in
place well regulatory gaps if those
regulations aren't tight um people
ultimately can have decreased trust that
The Regulators that are in place are
really looking out for their best
interestes or interests as a consumer or
as a
manufacturer um incorrect or fraudulent
data is something that we hear about a
lot um and ultimately that poor quality
really can lead to a negative or a poor
reputation for the Laboratories and for
science in
general we often hear about products not
matching labels that can really hurt the
brand because if you you know a news
release comes out stating that your
products have been found to not actually
contain what's listed on the label
that'll hurt your business but
ultimately poor quality it relates to
the risk of unsafe products unsafe
products cause consumer harm and that's
the absolute last thing that anybody
would want for the Cannabis industry
especially considering that many people
use these products for some sort of
medical benefit so really all of us in
the industry regardless of where we are
in the supply chain we really have to
establish expectations regarding quality
and what it means to us and potentially
keep in mind too what it means to the
consumer um um I was actually browsing a
website earlier this week for a hemp you
know hemp products just checking out
what was there and I saw a product that
had some very interesting like marketing
around it some really interesting claims
as to what the product can be used for
and when I scrolled down and looked at
the reviews the reviews all said this
product didn't work I didn't feel any
different it didn't do what I was what
it claimed that it could do and that's
really unfortunate and that's where I
think appropriate expectations are
really really critical um because if
anybody sets inappropriate expectations
it sort of sets us up for disappointment
and for ultimately a lack of trust so I
am closest to the laboratory and
analytical testing space so that's kind
of the hat that I will be wearing for
the rest of this
presentation so if we're thinking about
quality and we look at all of the
products that are on the market this is
really just some examples of things that
a consumer might see that are out there
none of these products that I'm showing
here were actually tested in any of the
studies that I'm going to present to you
in the rest of these slides really
they're just here as an example but if
we think about quality and what that
means to
us then we can better you know Define
the question that we're trying to ask so
in terms of these cannabis products here
I would say quality what's in these
products and how much of it is there so
we have our question and now we can work
on identifying what the tools might be
that we need in order to answer these
questions so I have a variety of
different Waters instrumentation shown
on this slide that can be used for
testing canabo in different consumer
products so for the known you can use
technology that can identify and
quantify the things that you expect the
cannabinoids that you know are there and
give you values that potentially could
go on to labels and things like that or
you can shift over and think about the
unknowns so you can think about what
canabo what cannaboids do I know are
there that I'm aware of that exist and
look for those while also keeping your
eyes out and looking and open for
potentially unknowns that you may not
expect so I'm going to talk about both
of these different types of Technologies
but first I will start with the knowns
and with that we will talk about liquid
chromatography with UV or mass detection
and a little bit a super uh super
critical fluid
technology so we're going to look for
the GN right so how much of these
specific analytes are present within a
cannabis product so I have a chart here
that shows 18 different cannabinoids
different names their retention times
things like that um Waters has developed
a method that can separate out and
quantify each of these 18 canabo in
various consumer products but on the
left side of your screen you see some
molecules um with some cannabinoids that
were you know typically um more
predominant or um more popular in the
market CBD THC CBN as well um a lot of
people focus on these specific C
cannabinoids because they have some sort
of value to them potentially they have
biological effects that people are
looking for so while there's value in
quantifying and looking at these you
know six I would say canabo 's a lot of
value in also looking at a broader list
seems like every year there's another
canabo that gets discovered to have some
sort of really interesting biological
effect um and it would be really
advantageous for the Laboratories to
have a method that has the ability to
detect and quantify a wide variety so
that nobody has to go back and do method
development after the fact you already
have data and a method that can meet a
broad set of needs right from the
start so if we want to determine what
are the known canabo and how much of
them are there in my products you can
follow a workflow that looks like this
so ultimately you would take your
product you would homogenize it in some
way whether you're using you know a
coffee grinder mortar and pestle maybe
or you know Technologies like the Geno
grinder or the freezer Mill to really
grind your samples up into a powder that
you can then go on and extract and get
into
solution once they're in solution you
may perform a variety of different
sample preparations maybe have some
catcher salts in there so that you can
really separate out the sugars and have
the canono in a layer that you can test
um more effectively maybe filter it um
and Waters also has an um an application
success guide or an sop that can guide
people who use our instrumentation how
to go about each of these steps to
quantify cannabinoids and extract them
and get them in the solution and then
once they're there then you would inject
them onto some sort of chromatographic
instrument
that will separate out all the
cannabinoids chromatographically and
allow you to quantify each of those
individually so one of the unique I
would
say benefits of the solution that Waters
has is that we've chosen to include Mass
spectrometry into the mix so usually and
most common people use some sort of
liquid chromatography with UV detection
to quantify canabo right this is an
example of one of our systems that are
shown here in the columns that we use
and then you can see that there are some
chromatograms over on the right side of
the page each of those Peaks represent a
different cannabinoid and each of them
are using a slightly different way to
detect them whereas the top chromatogram
shows the UV Spectra um and the middle
and the bottom actually show what those
peaks look like when you're finding and
detecting them through Mass spectrometry
um it's not always necessary um because
we commonly see cannabinoid that are in
higher abundance and that's usually the
ones that people are looking for but
having Mass spectrometry Gives You
almost like an additional piece of
information you would have retention
time and you would have UV absorbance as
a way to know that this is the canabo
that I'm looking for but masspec is like
another type of chemical fingerprint
that you can look at so that you're
totally confident that what you're
seeing is what you think it
is one of the other cool features or I
would say enhancements of using mass
spectrometry when you're t for canono is
that you actually have a little bit of
extra sensitivity so for example some of
these minor canabo are you know minor
they're in lower abundance but they
might be present in a variety of
different cannabis extracts that
somebody might be you know manufacturing
and producing
and sometimes UV just isn't sensitive
enough to really quantify those lower
level analytes that are in less
abundance so Mass spectrometry actually
gives you an extra order of magnitude
lower detection so that maybe you're
better able to quantify some of those
lowlevel analytes it's not
required but it can add some extra value
to your analyses if you're looking to
quantify some of the lower
levels so one of the ways that this
technology is used is for quality
control testing um some manufacturers
have it inhouse it's definitely the
go-to at um thirdparty testing labs and
you get data on you know cannaboid
content that can go on to be you know
included different labels um but you can
also use this technology to do a bit of
Market surveillance or even like market
research so we've heard commonly that
products have been shown to not match
their labels so in this chart here I
have a variety of different cannabinoids
listed all 18 and then some quantitative
data along the way for different types
of chocolates and different
gpies so in the little box that popped
up you can see I've highlighted Delta 99
THC and a variety of chocolates
and um the third number in the white
boxes after the parentheses you'll see
that's actually the percent of label
claim so for these Delta 9 products they
were a little bit over 100% of the label
claim that means they had a little bit
extra Delta 9 THC in them these numbers
aren't terrible they might be within
sort of the error of a method um but
it's something to be aware of certainly
as you're formulating products you would
at least hope that the products have at
least minimum what's listed on the lab
now when we move into the gummies
quantifying those against their label
claims we've got data all across the
board so for one gummy there was only
36% of the label claim actually in the
gummy one had over the label claim and
another one was a little bit less so
it's something to be aware of um Waters
did this study a couple of years ago we
weren't the first um but there were also
similar observations that were published
by some FDA sift sand researchers um
that reflected these results as well and
you can actually check that out in the
paper that I have listed
below so why don't the products match
their labels well um for a variety of
reasons that I've shown on this slide
here maybe there's errors in Sample prep
because it is sort of a finicky process
um product instability I think is really
worth considering um stability studies
and shelf life is something that I think
really needs to be considered um because
as products sit on the shelves they
degrade right uh especially if they have
exposure to light or if they're maybe in
a little bit of a warm environment um so
maybe that's why or that perhaps
inappropriate methods are used so I
won't belabor the point too much but I
did want to show that there is a really
interesting paper or uh um blog post
publication online um that was written
by infinite Cal and anresco Labs that
came out last year that really dives
into the logistics of how is inflated
THC um really harming the industry and
how do people actually do it um and they
did this in partnership with the
American Council of independent
Laboratories it's a great Organization
for Laboratories to come together and to
discuss best practices so I highly
suggest checking that out if you want to
learn
more so if Pro like labels not matching
the products that are in them was you
know enough of a problem we also have
been dealing with the rise of delta8 THC
products
theyve certainly skyrocketed in states
where there is not a legal adult use
cannabis you know framework um because
Delta eight products have some
intoxicating properties um and you can't
really miss them and they're sold in a
variety of different places so there's a
lot of um access to delta8 products that
maybe in legal states would be a little
bit different um there's some harm that
could be associated with these using
them and there's actually just a lot of
unknowns so Waters actually did a study
a handful of years ago where our
researchers in house um subjected CBD
oil to acid and heat treatment and then
tested them to see how those products um
or how the chemical composition of those
products changed so in the first
chromatogram on the left side you can
see those are standards those are known
analytes right the second Chom diagram
is when CBD oil was exposed to heat
treatment um and you can see that yeah
CBD is a large Peak there um it's
predominant there's some other little
small Peaks that are present um they
actually match the untreated CBD
chromatogram that's down at the bottom
so the heat treatment didn't do too much
um at least that we could detect here
but when CBD was exposed to acid and
heat in the third chromatogram you can
now see that there are a variety of
different Peaks that suddenly appear
within this chromatogram um one of which
was definitely Delta 8 um and there were
a variety of other you know analytes
that showed up because you're performing
organic chemistry you're doing synthetic
conversions using chemistry so that's a
little concerning um well Delta eight
products are you know created from CBD
by some you know chemical transformation
we did this on a small scale but on a
large scale that shows that there are
some potential you know new things that
are popping up in these extracts that we
should probably characterize and know a
little bit more about so how do we go
about doing that
well that's when you can go and move
towards some of the more advanced
technology including highres Mass Spec
and ion Mobility so that you can look
for the cannabinoids you know while also
gaining some extra information about
those
unknowns
so here I am showing a chromatogram um
of some standards and of a delta8 THC
distillate product that was provided to
us by one of our collaborators something
that was going out on the market so you
can see that every peak in these
chromatograms that are labeled with a
number are known we can see that in the
chart like one is CBD um six is CBL four
is delta8 THC we know the retention time
of those analytes and we also know that
they have a mass to charge ratio of
315 well if we go and look at the
distillate sample the bottom
chromatogram you can see that there's
some Peaks there that are labeled with
numbers we know what those analytes are
but then everything that's labeled with
a letter is an
unknown what are these unknowns how do
we go about discovering what these are
so that we can better understand if
these products are safe for
consumption so I'm going to zoom in on
this section of the chromatogram that
shows Peaks a b c and
d so if we take this delta8 THC
distillate sample and analyze it using
it um liquid
chromatography and um high resolution
Mass spectrometry we get additional
information with high resolution Mass
spectrometry we actually are able to
have a more precise measurement of the
accurate mass of these unknowns so we
can better Zone in in on what the
potential chemical formula is we can
also fragment it into pieces blast it up
so that those puzzle pieces that are you
know generated from fragmentation can be
sort of put back together in a way to
hypothesize what the potential structure
could be so we've got retention time
accurate Mass fragmentation data and
with that in our software um this was
you or tested using our new Zeo G3 qof
um on our UniFi software platform we can
take all of this data and feed it into
databases and say or get some uh
predictions of what these unknown
analytes might be so Peak D was what we
zoned in on and we found that um in sort
of the middle right of the slide there
are some potential component names those
are predicted analy IDs um so now that
we have maybe some predictions of what
this unknown D might be based on its
chemical features we can search the
literature and say huh do we know
anything about these compounds yet is
there any safety data that's associated
with it any sort of clinical studies and
from there we can say you know all right
well maybe this is less of a concern or
maybe it is something that needs to be
further addressed So based upon our
testing using the Zeo G3 qof Mass
spectrometer highres Mass we were able
to predict that this is unknown D is a
hexa hydroc canabal isomer and here's
just an example example of some of the
Publications that came out um that
mention this isomer that sort of have
some maybe pharmacological data about it
um this is a step in the right direction
towards better understanding what's in
these products but we can take it to
another
level and it gets a little bit more
complicated so I'm showing again that
chromatogram of the distillate sample
and one thing I want to show you is that
sometimes one Peak you know one spot in
a chromatogram it might look like one
Peak that doesn't always mean that it's
just one analyte represented there so we
tested this sample using our water
select series cyclic IMs I Mobility mass
spectrometry and it adds a different
dimension of Separation to whatever
analytes might be present in your sample
and the way it does that is through um a
different dimension of Separation ion
mobility and I think the easiest way to
show you how ion Mobility Works because
I could talk for two hours as an
introduction is really demonstrated well
by this little you know graphic that's
going to pop up so ultimately you can
have two pieces of paper or two
molecules with the same mass and you can
change the shape maybe they you know
exist in different three-dimensional
configurations and if you move them
through air the one that's more you know
expanded out will travel slower will
drop to the flooor slower than one
that's a little bit more condensed a
little bit more tightly bound right that
is essentially how I Mobility Works you
separate things out based upon their
three-dimensional you know positions in
Space the way the cyclic does this is
it's this kind of like RAC trck um setup
where you can send those ions and
analytes into this RAC trck it spins
around separates things out in space for
theoretically infinite passes and
ultimately you're able to separate out
maybe things that are almost identical
but slightly different so we did this
using um this system on this distillate
sample and we found that depending on
the number of passes or laps that you
take on that racetrack what was once one
Peak was actually two overlapping
compounds with the same mass the same
retention time and the same chemical
formula so here is a a different view of
the data from this instrument you can
see that we have Peak e
FG and two two is a known remember
letters are the unknowns so if we take
this section of the chromatogram we're
analyzing these samples and we only do
one pass through the race track we see
essentially Four
Peaks now if we do three passes through
our onon Mobility race track you can
start to see that those Peaks are kind
of blobbing out spreading out a little
bit that means that there was more than
one analyte underneath that sort of
chromatographic space and we never knew
that until we did IM Mobility so you can
see that F actually had two things
underneath it and two actually had two
things underneath it and you can see it
even better when you do six passes
through the ion Mobility
racetrack so that's can be a little bit
alarming um sometimes the more you know
the more you wish you didn't know right
um but now we know that there are even
more compounds within this
You Know distillate sample that need a
little bit more you know testing or
maybe um a little bit more work to
identify what they are and if they are a
hazard so we're asking ourselves now
what are these compounds what are they
do we know what they are are they a
concern so the one additional cool
feature of this instrument and this you
know advanced technology that allows you
to better understand the unknowns is
that you can separate things out within
that racetrack and you can actually
selectively send those ions into that
fragmentation cell blast them up into
pieces individually which you never
could do before so you get an even
closer I guess level of detail that can
help you determine what these unknowns
are because they fragment slightly
differently so in the right side of this
PowerPoint um slide you can see that 315
is the largest Peak that's there you
know but some of these little minor you
know Peak that are really hard to see
but they're labeled with numbers are a
little bit different and that helps
researchers to know maybe things are put
together a little bit differently
between these two molecules so they
might be pretty darn close to each other
but they are slightly different and
sometimes those slight differences can
make an enormous impact on human
health so now what that is the end of my
scientific story and what we have to
present at Waters more so a selection of
tools that can help a person better
understand what's in these products our
role is that we create these Advanced
Technologies and then put them in to the
hands of researchers and developers so
that they can really take this
instrumentation run with it and unlock
some of these really hard scientific
questions
so you know here's just another
selection of Publications um that have
really dove in to figure out what are
some of these impurities these unknowns
Within These to8 THC products and are
there something that we should be
concerned about so there were two
Publications in October and essentially
hot off the press within the past month
there was another publication in the
Journal of natural products by the Eli
research group at the University of
Mississippi that went on to further
characterize some of the impurities in
commercially marketed and sold delta8
THC products more research is needed
there's more happening every day there's
always something new to learn and
ultimately it's it's all about
protecting the consumer and the
industry
so I asked at the beginning of this
presentation is like how do you define
quality how do we know if these products
are high quality well It ultimately
depends on what quality means to
you I would say that having products
that aren't fully chemically understood
can cause me to pause um and I think it
causes many others to pause as well
um it's just something to be aware of
when we all consider our role in the
supply chain so how can the analytical
labs Champion quality within the
Cannabis industry well defining what
quality means and using fit forp purpose
methods is a great way for analytical
labs to make sure that their data are
the highest quality to support the
different products that they test and
analytical labs if they want to ensure
that their their service their testing
methods and their data are the highest
quality I think routine participation in
proficiency testing programs is really
important it's essentially a test for
the labs to say that their methods are
working as they need um and there's a
variety of different providers Emerald
scientific nist aoac International that
have different types of cannabis
proficiency testing programs that the
analytical lab industry can really you
know engage
in if you're here and listening today or
if you're at any of these conferences
that relate to cannabis science or
Botanical science um you're actively
engaging in contributing to the
scientific Community I know that that
there's a certain level of um you know
brand privacy that many like to you know
have including some of maybe the methods
that they use in order to accomplish
their goals but if you're able to
contribute to the scientific community
and share your challenges and your
successes it'll only bring the entire
industry up and ultimately speak up for
quality quality um there's a lot of
stuff happening in the Cannabis space I
feel like we often hear more about the
bad than the good um so I challenge
everybody here to really speak up for
quality and engage in the scientific
community and the conversation and share
how you can so that we can continue to
just really bring up the level of
science um to where it needs to be for
this product um there are a few
different ways that you can get involved
I mentioned the American Council of
independent Laboratories as one um USP
ASM both have stakeholder groups that
really work together to um improve the
understanding of cannabis and the safety
of consumers and those who work in the
industry and aoac international is
another organization that's really
championing fit forp purpose
methodologies so that is where my
presentation will wrap up I do have to
say a special thank you to provde
Laboratories they are a longtime
collaborator with Waters we have to
really we have a lot that we can thank
uh Chris hadala for and Andy Aubin for
both of them are at um Pro Chris is
actually one of the co-founders of pro
so we are very thankful for their
collaboration and their ability to share
samples with us I also want to thank
Maran tuig Katherine Leighton and Kim
Tran three fantastic scientists at
Waters corporation that were actually
the ones who had their hands on the
samples and we're doing the testing of
all of the data that I presented here
today I'm very fortunate that I get to
be a messenger of the the incredible
science that they they do and then I
also want to thank aoac International
ail and USP for just being incredible
you know venues for collaboration and
learning if you're not involved in any
of those today I would say sign up so
thank you all so much for listening to
my presentation today I appreciate every
moment that you spent here and if you
have any questions you can add them into
the chat box um or get a hold of me on
LinkedIn or by email and I'd be happy to
answer any of your questions or provide
any assistance that is needed so thank
you all I hope you have a great day and
enjoy the rest of the lab Roots
event